we taught our children to give Sanctuary
to the Jews and that's why only somebody
detached from history comes to those
very outrageous conclusions I don't know
if you've heard of this turn henal
directive no the Muslims proactively
went out to rescue the Jews from
anti-semitic protecting the Jews wearing
the nikab 2005 we tried to compromise
Israel withdrew from Gaza could have
been the biggest beautiful Resort on the
beach he was also a Zionist not look I
used to be a Zionist I'm a as you
mentioned I'm a holocaust Survivor he
was able to leverage this media
attention into several fundraisers where
he managed to collect a whopping in and
winning their hearts so much so that
many of the Jews entered Islam on the
basis they thought our religion doesn't
call on us for this our religion talks
about AMC how we should Israeli reporter
is Cohen investigated and determined
that the story wasn't true is
the I love you
you're when I was ready to talk about it
I would only talk to I was explaining
how much respect I have for the
oflc to
the
the now my next guest Sammy Hamdi is the
managing director at the international
interest who's also a political
commentator I'm going to get into this
very disturbing clip and I want him to
give us his feedback and reaction to it
because it seems like this is catching a
little bit of momentum so we're going to
put this out before more people start to
repeat some of these not facts far
beyond fiction we can no longer Embrace
this being Mr Nice Guy to the people who
are in Gaza because this is over a
thousand years of mothers teaching their
children grow up and kill Jews grow up
and kill Jews alum
how you doing for me thank you thank you
for coming in we getting straight into
it you see uh this is beyond fiction I
mean fairy tales what do you call this I
call this an incredible right-wing
propaganda incredible Israeli
multi-billion dollar PR propaganda and
also desperation desperation in this
idea that now you have people screaming
down the microphone saying that we
shouldn't play nice guy anymore but why
are they saying it they are saying it
because they are responding to a
phenomenon that is unfolding which is
what what I call the Great Awakening
which is that people are finally
beginning to see the cause for what it
is which is an apartheid settler project
against the Palestinians and now there
is this hysteria because that sounds
hysterical there is this hysteria that
is emerging which is calling on people
not to believe the Palestinian
narratives that for the first time have
finally broken through Israel's choke
hold over the Monopoly I know that
sometimes people when they hear this
kind of thing they think you know oh
this is the reaction is going to be
really bad and this shows that things
are becoming dangerous or the like and
part of that might be true but it's also
important to note that the widespread
message the widespread messaging of
messages such as this is a reaction to
what they perceive to be a threat and
the threat they perceive to be here is
not a military threat from Gaza or the
Palestinians it's the threat that after
75 years of portraying the Palestinians
as barbaric and inhuman the world is
beginning to see them as humans as
mothers as Fathers as the grandfather
who has the beard where for years
Hollywood kept presenting anybody with a
beard as somebody associated with
radicalism people saw a viral video
where a man in the beard dressed in
Muslim attire who is holding his dead
granddaughter and says the spirit the
soul of my
soul they are seeing this and they are
human these videos are humanizing the
Palestinians in a way that is provoking
that sort of Hysteria and that's why as
you said they're going Beyond fiction in
order to try to create multiple
narratives in a desperate attempt to
dehumanize the Palestinians after
failing in previous attempts with the
stories of beheaded babies with the sto
apparent stories of rape with the
apparent mistreatment of the hostages or
like all of which have since been
debunked you've been a practicing Muslim
obviously tell us uh what does Islam is
this part of the teach because she said
for over a thousand years Muslim mothers
have been taught to just hate Jews this
part of Islamic teaching just to hate
Jews because they're
Jews I think that when it comes to this
particular propaganda and messaging it's
important to note that those who say
this are very much detached from history
and the reason why I say that they are
detached from their own history and the
reason why I say this in particular is
that it's true that as Muslims it's very
easy to debunk this but it's important
to highlight that even in non-muslim
literature there is a resounding
consensus that the only example of real
coexistence between the religions based
on Justice and Harmony has only ever
truly existed in its objective form in
Muslim history it was Muslim Andalusia
that was they considered the epitome of
coexistence between Muslims Jews and
Christians so much so that when you look
at the rate of conversions from Judaism
to Islam under Andalusia they weren't as
fast as Christianity because the Jews
found a Haven within Muslim rule whereby
Allah sub wa tala in the Quran allowed
them to operate within their own laws
within their own societies inside the
Muslim State this was something ordained
by Allah subhana wa ta'ala himself when
Isabella kicked out the Muslims from
Spain and the Jews the Jews found Haven
not in Christian Europe which had which
had brutalized them not in white
supremacist anti-semitic Europe they
went to the Muslims because they knew
the Muslim tradition encouraged the
coexistence between the religions in a
way that Judea Christianity does not
even when you look ated it the only
country the only city in Europe that has
the nickname the Jerusalem of Europe and
before I go into Jerusalem of Europe why
is it called Jerusalem it's because
Jerusalem in Christian literature in
West literature Jerusalem is considered
a place of the coexistence of religions
but why is it considered the place of
coexistence it's because the Muslims
rule Jerusalem in such a way that Omar
brought back
the they brought back the Jews to live
in Jerusalem after they had been kicked
out by the Christians and establish a
system of coexistence that became such a
model of practice that Jerusalem as an
ideal became what people used to
describe as the ideal form of
coexistence and the only city in Europe
Eddie and you will know this as well
because you are from this country where
this city is the only city in Europe
that's called the Jerusalem of Europe
the Jerusalem being a reference that
this is the only city in Europe that the
westerns like to argue is a place where
coexistence works is Saro of Bosnia and
Saro became this Jerusalem of Europe by
their own recognition the reason why I
avoided the Islamic text is because the
non we're talking non-muslims they say
it I'm saying even in the non-muslim
literature they called s the Jerusalem
of Europe on the basis that when the
Muslims rulle Saro you see the synagogue
you see the church and the Masjid
because the Muslims believed it was
incumbent upon them to facilitate that
coexistence in a way that anti-semitic
Europe never did and it's important to
stress here that despite that idea that
that even beyond the idea of the
Jerusalem of Europe it's important for
us to be very blunt as well with regards
with regards to the tragedies and the
horrific atrocities that were committed
we should be blunt and we should
acknowledge them that it was the
Europeans the anti-semite Europeans that
gassed the that gassed the Jews it was
was the anti-semitic Europeans that put
the Jews under the Holocaust it was the
anti-semitic white supremacists that
kicked out the Jews and massacred them
in Spain it was the anti-semitic
Europeans that did the pgms in Warsaw in
Poland that massacred the Jews for no
other reason than they were Jews it was
the anti-semitic white supremacist
Europeans who came up with the Bal for
declaration which was not supposed to be
a gift of Palestine to the Jews so much
as an attempt to kick out in their words
the alien Jews from our society in the
words of the daily maale and it's very
interesting that when the Bal for de
ation was announced it was a Jewish the
only Jewish Member of Parliament who
stood up and said it's outrageous for
you to try to kick us out of the UK on
the basis of anti-Semitism that you
believe somehow we don't belong here
even in their own literature Eddie even
in their own literature they acknowledge
that they taught their children hate we
taught our children love they taught
their children to commit atrocities we
taught our children to build Havens they
taught their children to Massacre Jews
we taught our children to give Sanctuary
to the Jews and that's why only somebody
detached from history comes to those
very outrageous conclusions this is deep
I mean anybody so it wasn't Muslims
didn't have this kind of pro you
mentioned everybody but the Muslims
Muslims were welcoming Jews I want to
build this framework this foundation so
we can clear up any doubt that anybody
has anyone does a little bit of homework
looks into the history they're going to
come up with what you just mentioned
here this is interesting in Saro since
you mentioned Saro that the when the
Muslims there at that time they were
actually I interviewed some some people
in Bosnia they were saying how they were
um hiding the Jews in nikab they were
the to to protect them um in the cab
were in the Islamic dress is that yes
yes during the World War I the Muslims
and the bosnak people in Saro in the
whole the bosnan and heroa uh are
protecting the Jews wearing the nikab
especially inab Muslims would put this
on the Jews on this way the helping uh
kill to hide the hide the hide his house
so the Nazis wouldn't kill them yes yes
yes yes yes to protect protect the Jews
from the Nazis this is deep no it's but
but it's true and also the Ottoman
Empire sent ships to rescue Jews from
Spain like we're not talking about the
Jews turned up on the shores and we said
oh okay you know let's take them in no
the Muslims proactively went out to
rescue the Jews from anti-semitic white
supremacist Europe even though pictures
of the Jews from Europe who are coming
to Palestine after the Holocaust after
the brutality of what Europe did to them
they unfail the balance please don't do
to us what the Europeans did to us what
the anti-semitic white supremacist
Europeans did to us and that's why I
find it fascinating that what white
supremacist Europe tends to do the white
supremacist is they try to reflect their
atrocities or impose them on others in
that they were anti-semitic so they
accuse others of being anti-semitic
everything they did they are trying to
accuse the Muslim Muslims of doing and
the reason why Muslims are so baffled by
it is because the Muslims look at their
own Rich tradition in history and they
say yo guy we did it already we even
today in the universities when they
study coexistence Andalusia is the
number one example they all use Saro is
one of the top examples that they use
they struggled to find a single European
city where they can legitimately argue
that there was Harmony between the
different religions because white
supremacist Europe didn't believe in
coexistence they believed in subjugation
they believed in massacr even in the
Hollywood films Yeah Eddie even in the
Hollywood films I don't know if anybody
has seen the film Kingdom of Heaven with
Orlando Bloom where they talk about
Salah and they they try to paint Orlando
Bloom as ban as some sort of hero and
there's a scene right at the end where
ban says okay I will surrender the city
but how do I know that you won't do to
the
Christians you won't Massacre the
Christians because Balan is aware that
when the Christians took Jerusalem they
massacred 70,000 of the population
Muslims and Jews and he says how do I
know you won't do that to the population
in there and goes because I am I'm not
you you're not my teacher and that's why
I think it's fascinating that even in
the Quran when Allah subhana talks about
the he
says is there any better speech than one
who calls to Allah and does good deeds
and says I am from the Muslim we tend to
forget that the next aah gives context
to that aah which
is the good deed and the bad deed are
not equal they are anti-sites we are
that doesn't make us anti-mite they are
islamophobic that doesn't make us racist
they are racist that doesn't make us in
other words just because they do vile
atrocities we've never taken them as our
teachers in the way that we treat the
Jews we never and the reason why these
cities existed Andalusia and Saro and
these other places where the Jews were
able to live in the same era in which
the Jews were being persecuted by white
supremacist anti-semitic Europe the
reason why these cities were able to
exist is because the Muslims even in
those environments never took them to be
the teachers is they took
allaha where he says in the
Quan conduct yourself in that which is
best for it may be the one who is an
enemy today tomorrow becomes your
warmest Ally and we are seeing it today
one of the things that they find these
white supremacists and those zionists
the reason they are struggling so much
Eddie is because they are seeing that as
a result of the of the Muslim and the da
of the Muslims one more and more people
are entering Islam but two more and more
allies are aligning themselves with
Muslim causes Eddie you saw the Jewish
cousins do the sitting in the Congress
demanding a ceasefire you've been to
protest before you've seen the Jews join
us and say we stand against the
ceasefire they're doing it because of
the daa the Muslims are giving and also
because those particular Jews know their
history they know that historically
there's never really been a problem
between the Jews and the Muslims in so
far as the Muslims living side by side
with the Jews and to finish on this
point anybody who opens the book wrote
to Mecca by Muhammad Assad Muhammad
Assad writes at a time before is Israel
is established Muhammad Assad says that
in Palestine where he was living the
Jews and the Muslims live side by side
in complete Harmony but these the influx
of Europeans coming in particularly
Europeans coming in are agitating and
causing a rift in society that is
exacerbating these differences because
they refuse to engage with the society
and look down on the Jews who support
the coexistence and the reason I want to
finish on this particular point on this
topic is to highlight that Zionism in
its essence was always about ethnic
cleansing and genocide it was something
that was so disgusted by the Islamic
principle of respect and coexistence
they were so disgusted that Islam called
for respect of it was so disgusted that
Islam would uphold a system of justice
whereby
Ali the fourth of Islam would go to a
court case and he would be against the
Jew and they would be arguing over a
plot of land or the like and the judge
would would give a ruling in favor of
the Jew and then look at and say you
look upset with the judgment and would
say no judge I'm not upset with the
Judgment I'm upset that you called me AB
Hassan but didn't call him with a you
honored Me by calling me by K if you use
K on me use K on him if you will call me
Abu Hassan you call me Abu on his son to
elevate him in status to show you how
Islam even in something as the title
with which you address the Jew is
something that Islam demands that you
uphold Justice in the zionists were
disgusted that Islam respected the Jew
so they wanted to dehumanize the Muslim
to try to convince the world that
somehow we're the ones who are the ones
who oppressing the Jews and you have a
lot of academics you have a lot of um
historians Jewish historians who also go
ahead and are honest and they come out
and say Islam saved the jury I want to
take it back to the last and final
message sent to mankind prophet Muhammed
peace and blessings be upon him did he
at at his
time have the ability if he wanted to if
Muslims were really against Jews to
annihilate Jews at that time did he have
the power if he wanted to the prophet
Muhammad sallahu alaihi wasallam when he
enters Medina he's aware there's a large
Jewish population he's aware that and
Kaz the largest tribes have given him
Allegiance and he's aware that the Jews
have a sensitivity towards a man who's
just turned up at the gates claiming to
be a prophet of Allah subhah wa ta'ala
bringing a religion that they fear will
supplant their religion they fear that
Muhammad sallallah alaihi wasallam is
about to bring about revolutionary
change in Medina that might result in
existential crisis against the Jews
answering your question they believe
that an existential crisis primarily
because his message was resonating with
the two main powers in Medina and that
these two main powers who had been
Waring for Generations fighting and
killing each other for Generations
suddenly laid down their arms over the
as a result of the message of this man
an orphan illiterate orphan who had come
from Mecca and they had offered him uary
the Jews were concerned what this
message would mean for them the prophet
Muhammad s alaihi wasallam goes to them
and says let us establish The Pact of
Medina whereby if somebody attacks you
we promise to defend you if somebody
oppresses you we promise to defend you
if somebody comes after and violates you
we swear before Allah subhah wa ta'ala
we will fight with you to the end for
your rights even though you are Jewish
and we are Muslims butet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam with the
messenger from Allah himself doesn't say
accept Islam or I will Slaughter you
doesn't say accept Zionism or I will
Massacre you doesn't say accept my
message or I will eradicate you and
commit genocide and ethnic cleansing and
turf you from your homes the way the
zionists are doing toaz the prophet
Muhammad sallallah alaihi wasallam says
your homes are yours your lands are
yours your Society is yours your laws
are yours your Customs are yours and we
Swear to protect it on the B basis of
this pact of Medina and you will promise
to protect us when our rights are
violated and the Jews were so surprised
by it then the Hypocrites were so
horrified by it because the Hypocrites
hoped that they could cause a division
between the Jews and the Muslims and
they were so stunned that the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam had
ruined their plan with kindness that he
had ruined their plan with injunction in
Islam that imposed upon us an obligation
to show respect and uphold the rights of
of the Jews even though they are not
Muslim the Hypocrites believed that we
have a mantra like the Zionist where we
should be massacring those who disagree
with us they were shocked that Allah
subhana wa tala was telling his Prophet
don't force them into the religion
convince
them convince
them debate with them in that which is
best say to my Believers that do that
which is
best the best speech is the one who
calls to Allah not the one who kills in
order for them they were stunned that
this man was coming in subverting all
the traditions and customs of the people
who came before him where they would be
violent in imposing their views they
wanted Islam to be a religion that
imposed Itself by force they were
shocked to find that the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam was
coming in and winning their hearts so
much so that many of the Jews entered
Islam on the basis they thought our
religion doesn't call on us for this our
religion talks about Amal how we should
Massacre you know women and children and
the like even when people talk about
banua and the Betrayal that happened
afterwards banua was Jewish law not
Muslim law because they implemented
Jewish law on
this the prophet Muhammad says which law
do you want to impose on them is it
Muslim law or Jewish law and S mu says
to the Jews and the Jews they want the
Jewish law implemented on them not the
Muslim law it's the Jewish law that is
implemented on and that's the important
distinction that is supposed to be made
here in that when the prophet M entered
Medina the reason the Medina Covenant is
studied even today is because it was
revolutionary in its time that a man
would come with a message from Allah
subhah wa ta'ala but tell people I'm not
here to force you into it please give me
a chance to plead with you to enter it
and I think that's why the prophet mam
wasallam when a Jewish course was
passing by him in a funeral he stood up
to show respect to it even if Allah told
him don't do it again but it showed you
the humanity in the heart of the Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
his approach to the Jews which is the
example for us and that's why I I I
always say and I love Omar MTAR
statement the LI Libyan Li Liberation
leader where when they captured Italian
soldiers and his soldiers they said
let's torture and kill them the way they
did us let's rip their limbs off the way
they do to us let's electrocute them the
way they do to usar looks at them
horrified and says they are not our
teachers the Muslim says they are not
our teach the Muslim says they are not
our teachers and that's why I say for
any everybody listening to this they are
not our teachers when we talk about our
relationship with the Jewish population
Netanyahu is not our teacher blinkin is
not our teacher Biden is not our teacher
these people committing atrocities are
not our teacher even when they commit
atrocities we read in the
Quran the good deed and the bad deed are
not equal Allah doesn't tell us to
respond with the same atrocity Allah
tells us that bad deed is not equal to
the good deed and the prophet is our
example in that when their rights are
violated we stand with them and when
they are oppressors we were ready to
stand against them but the point is the
Rel relationship is one of justice
justice doesn't belong solely to the
Muslims alone it also belongs to the
Jews and the Christians and in their own
history this is why I finish on this
point in their own history forget
Islamic history in their own history
this is why I emphasize I started with
their history in their own history they
acknowledge that the only religion in
history that gave Sanctuary to the Jews
or any persecuted religion that was
persecuted by the white supremacist of
the Western World they always found
sanctuary in Islam and some of their
greatest writings emerged not in Europe
but emerg in Muslim societies because
they had the freedom to do so this is
really deep I mean this leaves no doubt
uh you mentioned um you mentioned a lot
of things uh it had me think when you
said our cousins um this is like a term
of endearment why are you going to call
someone your cousin you know if you if
you hate them if you're you're you're
teaching your children like Michelle
Bachman former congresswoman is talking
about uh if you have this hate and
you're being taught to kill them and
then you made a distinction between Jews
and Zionism uh for for the average
person who who doesn't know the
difference uh how would you define and
make help them understand that Judaism
between Zionism and the two one of the
things that is worth noting is that when
you go to these protests or when you see
the Jews doing the sitting in Congress
or when you see the Jewish voice for
peace or when you see these other
organizations they are sincere Jews who
are standing against the violent Zionism
that's being implemented in Palestine we
see many Jewish rabbis come out and say
Zionism is not part of Judaism the
ethnic cleansing and genocide is not
part of Judaism and I believe them to be
sincere and that's why there's a
distinction between these Jews who
uphold Justice even if it belongs to a
people that are not their own and
between Zionism which is a settler
apartheid Colonial project which was
founded by an atheist secular Jew or
atheist Jew who came out and said that
we need a Haven one thing Eddie I will
say is this I sympathize with the roots
of Zionism and I explain what I mean
Zionism doesn't emerg from a vacuum
Zionism emerges because the white
supremacists of the western world are so
atro atrocious in the calamities that
they that they inflict on the Jewish
population their anti-Semitism is so
deeply embedded it's so vile it's so
violent it's so brutal we're talking
pgms we're talking Mass massacres of
Jewish populations we're talking
Holocaust we're talking about the
persecution in their jobs we're talking
about persecution in society we're
talking about newspapers doing horrific
cartoons where they show Jews with long
noses and accusing them of being all
these various different things Zionism
emerges in this environment where the
Jews say to themselves that these
anti-semitic white supremacist of the
western world who are today trying to
preach morality and values that somehow
are they believe to be superior to
everybody else the the treatment their
treatment at the hands of these white
supremacists was so violent and brutal
that they believe the only solution was
to establish a Haven for themselves
where they will no longer be persecuted
they wanted sanctuary and security from
who not the Muslims that they claim
today of a thousand years somehow their
children were taught to hate they wanted
Sanctuary from the white supremacist
Western World they wanted Sanctuary from
the white supremacist they were willing
to go anywhere Argentina Uganda anywhere
away from these white supremacists who
are so racist so anti Semitic that we
can't live in their societies we need to
establish a society for ourselves in
this I sympathize in the Muslim World
they saw Justice they didn't see it in
the white supremacist anti-semitic world
I sympathize with that but Zionism
became an idea of ethnically cleansing a
land that did not belong to them for the
sole purpose that somehow they believe
themselves to be a chosen people Allah
says in the Quran that when benu is used
to treat people bad they used to be told
why do you treat people this way and
they used to
say we you can't blame us for the way
that we treat an unlettered people or
people who are below us the zionists
argued Europeans by the way ironically
not the Jews of MB or the Jews of you
know the Middle East or the Jews
elsewhere the European Jews turn up to
Palestine and they preach this idea of
Zion ISM in which they tell the Jews who
are living in coexistence that what do
you think of the idea where we kick out
people who've been in their homes for
thousands of years let's kick them out
take their land take their homes and
take it for ourselves because we are a
chosen people why don't we commit
genocide and a neba and kick them out in
1948 kick out 700,000 Palestinians for
no other reason then we want their land
and we want to establish it as an
ethnocentric Jewish State this is
Zionism the IDE D that they want to
commit ethnic cleansing of a land to
secure a state that belongs solely to
them whereby they can act with impunity
against the rest of the population the
irony being is a Zionism is the very
copy of the anti-semitic white
supremacist ideology that they fled from
so they suffered under an ideology in
white supremacist Western Europe that
said you are aliens you don't belong
here this is a white state for Christian
and Jews don't have any place here it's
almost as if they graduated from that
University the Zionist and said with
this model though it persecuted us
wouldn't it be great if we did it to
somebody else and so they turn up on
Palestine they do exactly what was done
to them they Massacre the local
population ethnically cleanse the areas
Turf them from their homes impose laws
to persecute them identical copy the
traumatized does do the same the the
abused is now doing the same thing the
abuser did very weird syndrome that is
taking place this is Zionism and this is
why the Jews were horrified by what the
Zionist did many Jews were horrified by
what the Zionist did the Jews who
understand Judaism have come out and
they've said that Judaism does not
believe in the genocide and ethnic
cleansing some of you gone to far as to
say the reason they don't have a state
is because God doesn't give us a state
because we betrayed our prophets they
have that in their own literature
Zionism is not a religious movement it's
a political movement designed to achieve
the supremacy of One race over another
it's an apartheid supremacist ideology
almost identical to the very white
supremacist anti-semitic ideology that
they fled from and they were brutalized
under it's interesting you mentioned the
Theodor herzo who who I call this is
like more the prophet because these
people are not really following the
prophet Moses they're following uh
someone who was an atheist and the uh
founding members of the movement were
atheist they really didn't even believe
in God but they believe that God
promised them the land this is very very
interesting very ironic it's like say we
don't believe in religion but we'll take
the part of religion that that we like
uh you uh beautifully explained the uh
Medina Charter and Prophet Muhammad he
had the power he could have annihilated
every every Jew there but uh this is a
proof now um that Allah didn't let him
he didn't let yes you I'm not saying
Prophet ever thought about it that he
never thought about it at all but I'm
saying he was a messenger from Allah
subhana wa tala so he was conveying the
message of Allah subhana wa tala so when
he doesn't do that it's because Allah
subh never asked him to do it ever and
then uh I want to just move on to um one
of the Khalifa of uh Islam uh for the
non-muslim audience like a president
what would you define that as
leader Theif the elected leader chosen
by consensus so now he's coming back and
if you can take this away and he's
coming back and taking over Jerusalem
from the Christians and for how many 600
years the Jews were kicked out and then
now om he comes and repopulates
Jerusalem with Jews is this correct the
story of it is magnificent because on
his way to Jerusalem yeah he's riding a
mule yeah and Jerusalem at that time
bear in mind it's a very prestigious
Global City and the Muslims have taken
it and mu comes to Medina and says to we
have taken Jerusalem we've taken it so
gets ready to go to receive the keys of
Jerusalem as he's approaching the they
say to him you are Theif now of the
Muslim of the Muslims surely you should
be riding something more prestigious
surely you should be riding Etc he's on
a mule he's he's on a mule you know he's
going to show you what what these Muslim
leaders were like and how yes and he
turns around and he says Allah subhah we
were a humiliated people we were
a we were the most humiliated of people
and Allah gave us Glory through Islam
and W if we were to see glory in
anything but Islam surely Allah will
humiliate us once more I will not enter
Jerusalem to show arrogance on the
people that we have conquered I will not
enter Jerusalem to say that Islam has
arrogantly come in to subjugate them I
will not enter Jerusalem on the basis
that I've come in to persecute in the
way the Christians did I will come in to
show them what Islam is really about and
when he enters Jerusalem and he orders
that the Jews be restored to to to that
they be allowed to come and live in
those areas once more that white
supremacist Christian them anti-Semitic
Christian them refuse to allow the Jews
are stunned not that they are coming
back but that that somehow argues that
this is the Islamic thing to do that
this is the Muslim thing to do and
there's another fascinating story in
this as well in that is reported to have
entered a church to show how the CH the
white supremacist are not our teachers
he enters the church and the Christians
are saying to him the time for prayer
came in they said to him
yeah you may pray here if you wish we
don't
mind now Scholars say that it's
permissible for him to have prayed in
that church but he turns around to them
and he says I will not pray here they
say why he says I fear people will come
after me and they will say Omar prayed
in this church and they will tear down
this church and they will build a musk
on top of it so he said it's better for
me you look at the foresight that had
even in his treatment of our cousins as
I as I say as I say sometimes in the
idea that you think about it what is it
that made restore the Jews to to
Jerusalem tell them you can come back
and live here after the Christians
kicked you out after 600 years as you
mentioned what made om say to the
Christians I don't want overzealous
Muslims to come and tear down your
churches something that is forbidden in
Islam when people say churches are
converted to mosques it's usually
because the Christians are selling their
churches selling the land and the
property it's never through taking
violent by force the point is what is
driving to show this attitude to Jews
and Christians that the Jews and
Christians don't even show themselves
what is it that made om show this
attitude to people who are not Muslim
that they those non-muslims were
treating themselves in that manner it
was an injunction it was Islam that
inspired Omar it was Islam that
encouraged that the ultimate aim of
Islam if you are trying to get people to
become Muslim you must convince them
freely to accept Islam Allah does not
accept somebody to be forced converted
to Islam and that laid the foundations
for
coexistence and it laid the foundations
of the to do what was not being done
anywhere else in the world at that time
which is to proactively facilitate the
coexistence and that's why I I want to
mention I want to really emphasize this
point that it wasn't just om on his own
or the prophet Muhammad sallallah alaihi
wasallam at coming with human being
thoughts on coexistence they were being
Guided by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala who
ordained in the Quran that this is what
Islam is about Islam is about granting
the rights to everybody irrespective of
their religion and that's why comes in
it's Islam that inspires him to bring
the Jews back and Islam that inspires
him to uphold the rights of the
Christians and in my opinion I finish on
this
point this is why there was so much
animosity to Islam the animosity to
Islam in my opinion was never about the
battles or about the conquer or about
the conquests it was never about any of
that the animosity towards Islam was
that it was so incredible and Majestic
in the values it preached and the
Transformations it brought about in
individuals that Christendom and
zionists were so horrified by what Islam
preached they were so taken aback by it
of the kindness of the way that Islam
promoted that coexistence that it's sort
of like no I can't have people believe
this message it's too nice a message
it's too wonderful a message I need them
to be brutal like me I need them to
commit atrocities like me that's why
they hate Islam it's the fact that it
inspires Justice where they want to
uphold Injustice I'm going to push back
just a little bit uh for the skeptic and
someone who's out there that's their
propaganda so we covered and you
eloquently you went and gave context to
at that time we see what the prophet the
last and final messenger sent to man
peace and blessings be upon him he
wanted to establish peace we we're going
to protect you we're going to work in
harmony then you have treachery that was
committing okay so now you're breaking
the rules and you're trying to
assassinate the uh the head of state
consequent treachery so if somebody
tries to bring up isolated in you have
the general what is happening we're
trying to live coexistence you have your
rights you you can go ahead and even
according to God's law Sharia now you
can govern according to your religious
uh you have your own religious rights
it's not like something can be amended
in the law and now you could be taken
out it's guaranteed rights the people of
the book is that correct yes so now what
do you like to say when people try to
bring up maybe some isolated incidences
say oh look here uh they were oppressed
or in this situation have you had this
come up and how do you like to address
that I think the main thing that comes
up is Ben which was the when the after
the the Jewish population betrayed the
Muslims when they were really that's the
main thing you see come the main thing
they always bring it up they say look
what the Muslims did to the Jews in the
way that the men and the the the men
were killed and the women enslaved and
and they always mention it and we're not
scared scared to discuss these things
not scared to discuss these things and
I'll tell you why here is the
context in Islamic
law and I'll give two examples in the
Battle of for those who were interested
in reading about it it was a defeat of
the Muslims at the hands of qur who were
beating so the Muslims were winning and
then the archers on a hill they got
excited about The Spoils of War they
abandoned their position and KH who
would lat to become the sword of Allah
and Muslim comes around the mountain and
he hits the Muslims from behind and the
Muslims are defeated in that
battle understanded military law those
who came down from the hill should have
been executed for disobeying the law the
in American military law in UK military
law it's established military law that
the punishment is usually caught Marshal
Allah subh sends down an
Ayah yeah Muhammad if you are harsh on
them and you apply this rule the rest of
your people will leave you so Allah
says pardon them ask forgiveness for
them and not only that he says bring
them back into your consultation after
they have led to the defeat of the
Muslims in battle bring them back we
always say I forgive but I never forget
Allah tells him bring them back and
Allah tries to assure the prophet and
says if you fear they will make the
mistake
again once you've decided on put your
trust in Allah that he will protect you
from the effects of their betrayal the
point I'm saying is look how Islam deals
with betrayal in the military sense now
look at the Betrayal of the interest of
the Muslims when the prophet is about to
launch his army to go to F mea to open
Mecca to go to Mecca itself qur don't
know the Muslims are coming this is
after the Treaty of Hud has been broken
when the qures killed the Muslims a man
worries about the fate of his family so
he leaves Medina under the cover of
night and he tries to go to mecah to
tell them the Muslims are coming prepare
yourselves in other words he's telling
them get ready the he's betraying the
Muslims he's saying they're coming
prepare yourselves I'm giving you
information in advance to give you an
advantage over the Muslims because
they're coming a military Advantage when
they catch him and he comes back this is
a betrayal of the full magnitude what
does the prophet Muhammad sallu alaihi
wasallam impose on this individual when
the are saying he should be executed for
his betrayal the prophet Muhammad
wasallam says he fought in bad how do
you know that Allah has not forgiven
those who have fought in B in other
words they forgive the treason the
reason I say this look at the capacity
in Islamic law for pardoning even a
crime of
treason now let's look at Jewish law
which was what was implemented on
banua banua what was implemented was not
Muslim law or Islamic law which has room
for pardoning crimes including treason
as we saw in bad as as we saw with the
person who tried to betray the Muslims
in bad they wanted Jewish law to be
implemented on them and that's why
sometimes when they use these arguments
I keep I I always say I say maybe if
they had asked for Islamic law to be
implemented on them it wouldn't have
happened but the Jews insisted on their
own law being implemented on them surely
in many ways it's a sign that Islamic
law might be a bit better for the
population than your Jewish law than
Judaism and that's why I think for these
issues when they bring isolated isolated
incidents the reason they bring isolated
instance is because the context kills
them the context makes them feel
uncomfortable to tell somebody that was
Jewish Lord under Judaism not Islamic
law really make hurt it's like you're
trying to say Islamic law is better and
as I said earlier the epitome of
coexistence Muslims the epitome of
Justice Muslims the Breakthrough in
sciences that led to Adam Smith and his
the is Muslims Allah subh inspired us
with this knowledge and that's why you
always argue that context is important
because once you encourage the context
they discover things such as how Islamic
law dealt with instances of treason I'm
not saying Islamic law doesn't have
punishments for treason such as for
example like other things and and
execution and the like what I'm saying
is the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam demonstrated that there
were instances where even something like
treason could be forgiven something that
didn't exist in Judaism so when they
look at those atrocities I always say to
them guys it was Jewish law that was
implemented they wanted Jewish law to be
implemented and I wish sometimes that it
was Islamic law that had been
implemented for it might have turned out
to be better I mean if you want to get
technical they should be actually
because uh they end up denying uh
they're waiting around for a messiah
which is actually Jesus and then if they
would accept him then they end up
accepting Prophet Muhammad and then they
would they wouldn't have to be uh
committing uh this genocide based on
certain verses in the Bible which if you
look at chapter 5:32 is address it's
specifically addressed to the children
of Israel not to kill innocent men women
and children who they're coming AMC and
you have these cases of genocide
straight in the in the Bible in the
first five books I I I I've T spoken to
many different Scholars they think this
is uh where they changed the text but
one thing also that is that is very
interesting yes is is that this idea
that when you're talking about the the
Jewish populations and and and the
Christian populations all the like it it
is worth no that one of the reasons that
they dislike the context is that even
with B which is the main example they
use when the Hypocrites go to the Jewish
population and tell them this is the
golden opportunity to wipe out the
Muslims MH so when we're talking about
we're not talking that the that that s
people turned up and oppress the Jews
the Hypocrites the maaf they go to the
Jewish population in Medina and tell
them if you guys stab them in the back
if you go and hit them from behind all
the Arabs have G we can wipe out the
Muslims but this is why I think a lot of
zionists don't like context because the
reaction of the Jewish leader before he
agrees to the treason he actually says
but Muhammad has treated us well like
the Muslims have treated us really what
for what reason would we betray them why
would we commit treason when we've been
treated better probably than than we
have been treated in this particular
City yes ultimately they agreed to
betray the Muslims afterwards that
particular Community but the point is
that that context think about that
statement we've been treated so well by
Muhammad it hurts them so you're there
saying that the Muslims were vile and
they were this and whatever by your own
admission this is why I've started a lot
of a lot of our discussion I keep
pushing back when you keep saying what
does it say in Islam and I'm telling you
no let's let let's talk about what they
said yes by the ruin admission he says
it's recorded even their books Muhammad
has treated us well why does he say that
and I think that's what hurts them the
most in their own text in their own text
okay so we covered a lot and I wanted to
build this purposely on this Foundation
to dispel this narrative that's being
pushed on Fox news on all the major
networks that it's a Muslim Jew thing
people who are motivated by hatred that
they hate Jews they hate Israel and we
just dispel this anyone who sincere
looks at this I mean there's no shadow
of a doubt left so let's go into future
now let's common day and then you also
you talked briefly on the nakba what
happened so Muslims and Jews were living
in in a relative peace for over a
thousand years injury Jerusalem and then
they came over uh fleeing the
anti-Semitism from the Christians not
the Muslims and then they came over to
Palestine they welcomed and then what
happened you had the displacement of
almost uh uh over
800,000 innocent human beings who had
welcomed you in your home and they were
talk about briefly about
this what was called the NBA is it also
I've heard that this is something that
you can't in Israel you're not supposed
to even talk about this you can't bring
this up is there's a law against it so
the British have the Mandate of a
Palestine they've taken it from the
Ottomans Ottomans have lost it after the
first world war the Ottomans have lost
it at a time when sulan abdulhamid iI is
toppled in the early 1900s The Young
Turks come to power The Young Turks are
a secular group they they already lay
the foundations of Bringing Down the
caliphate which they create a very
Turkish Centric state which is one of
the reasons that encourages or gives
allows the Arabs in the Arabian
Peninsula to create a semi- legitimacy
to revolt against the Ottomans they turn
around and they say look it's no longer
an Islamic empire it's become a Turkish
Empire Under The Young Turks we don't
owe any obligation to it and then
afterwards the the Ottoman Empire
collapses the British take over the pal
Palestine o but they struggle to rule
over Palestine at the same time however
when they're in Palestine the Muslims
and Jews are living side by side B for
declaration comes in which they say to
the Zionist movement you can have
Palestine you can start moving in
problem is many Jews are not moving to
Palestine so they end up providing
Financial incentives in order for the
European Jews to come when the European
Jews turn up the society starts to
become agitated why the Muslims and the
Jews are used to living side by side
they have a lot of relationships
business relationships some are even
marrying between because Muslims can
marry and good point stop there if
Muslims hate Jews how are they allowed
to to marry to marry exactly that kills
the argument so so and and there's a lot
of intermarrying as well there are
families with Jewish and Muslim you know
relatives blood relatives as well the
Europeans turn up they've been
brutalized they've been tortured they've
been persecuted by white supremacist
anti-semitic westerners anti-semitic
Europe they turn up but when they turn
up they don't respect the coexistence
they look at the Jews who are living
side by side with the Muslims as almost
self-hating Jews as traitors as those
who are not committed to the cause of
ethnic cleansing and creating a state
exclusively for the Jews where no other
people live in the Jews as the same with
the same rights as the Jews so they
start agitating they Muhammad Assad in
his book wrote to meca Muhammad Assad
was born a Jew his name was Leopold
Weiss he was born in Austria he was an
Austrian Jew who later became Muslim so
at the time when he's in Palestine
writing he hasn't become Muslim yet he's
still a Jewish journalist in Palestine
and he writes at the time that the
zionists who are coming from Europe are
agitating a society that was by all
means quite harmonious in the way it was
operating between the religions when
they come the zionists start agitating
and putting out propaganda calling for
the displacement of Palestinians and
establishing of a Jewish State at that
time there were minority so nobody's
taking them seriously but in 1928
1929 there are gangs that are emerging
that are provoking the Muslim
populations and we seeing scuffles take
place on the streets and the Arabs
essentially respond to that and the big
Riot and Revolt takes place which
results in a a number of uh uh
aggressions taking place that leads to
Zionism securing a greater sympathy
amongst the local
Jews as a result more gangs are created
that later become the IDF later become
consol as IDF later
on as after World War II there's the
Holocaust the world is sympathizing with
the Jewish population as a result of 6
million Jews being killed by who by
anti-semitic white supremacist Europe
they commit an atrocity of which the
Muslim world has no equivalent by any
stretch of the imagination it's
something that somehow I always argue
that the white supremacist are experts
in in terms of these kind of things
putting Jews in gas Chambers and gasing
them be innovating in the way that they
kill the Jews and the like the horrors
are such that there is the sympathy
towards the Jewish population the
zionists take advantage of that sympathy
to begin to mobilize their gangs to
surprise the mus Muslims who their Dean
is telling them to uphold coexistence
and to to uphold the rights of their
cousins the Jewish gangs turn up one day
in the night time and they start kicking
out the Palestinian families one by one
the Palestinian families are stunned
shocked they have no idea what's
happening no idea what's going on
they're being killed and they're being
turfed from their homes and so they move
out 700,000 NE about 800,000
Palestinians are kicked out of their
homes the Arab states many of which are
still colonized are so horrified some
try to invade but the white supremacist
anti-semitic Europe sees an opportunity
to keep the Jews there to keep the we
don't want them coming back to Europe so
if they're being invaded we'll help you
we just don't want you to come back to
Europe we'll help you stay there they're
invading you we'll help you keep this
state and that kind of and that leads to
1948 the first defeat and then
afterwards uh when the Arab states start
getting liberated from colonization they
make another attempt again that fails
then you have 1967 1973 but the point is
that generally it happened in a way that
can only be described as barbaric but
also the agitation of the society began
with the Aral of the Zionist Jews from
Europe and the Muslim population were
taken by surprise because and and it's
very similar to sometimes we look at
Trends initially when we read Fox News
or the like once upon a time we used to
laugh at Fox News we say this is a
minority Trend that can never have any
influence today we see that fox use the
way it spreads for fake news and and all
these others it's become a serious
problem that needs to be addressed and
that's very similar to how the Arabs
treated Zionism in that it was an idea
that nobody truly believed would become
some would manifest itself in the way
they did they were taken by surprise
anti-semitic Europe didn't want the Jews
to come back to Europe so they said keep
that state over there and as a result
it's it developed into this very awkward
relationship all right I want to get
your response to this this is uh what's
commonly pushed out there in the media
and is one of the major talking points I
want to see how you respond to this I
cannot remind you enough how many times
Israel has tried to compromise with a
two- State solution so let me just read
the facts cuz I don't speak on a motion
1936 appeal commission Israel accepted
Palestinians rejected 1947 un partition
plan rejected and then the Arab leagues
waged a war the next day that led to the
alleged nakba of displacement because
they said get out of here let's kill all
the Jews and you'll take the land back
the next day 1967 cartoon resolution
rejected by the Palestinians 2,000 Camp
David Summit Arafat and AUD Barack
rejected by the Palestinians 2005 we
tried to compromise Israel withdrew from
Gaza could have been the biggest
beautiful Resort on the beach and the
best piece of land that they had to
offer instead they turned it into a
terrorism Haven 2008 HUD Merit offered a
Palestinian State and it was once again
rejected you'll hear this and it paints
a picture like they've always tried to
have peace but how can you have peace
when someone and she lists all these
years they tried they tried and this
year and this date and they were like
rejecting
peace one of the things
is when it comes comes to spinning that
particular narrative it's wonderful
you've heard this obviously I've heard
this it's wonderful when you take things
out of context yeah the idea being that
you know if let's
say let's let's do it this way
everything she said is correct
everything she said is absolutely
correct the appeal commission suggested
you know a state for the for the Jews
and state for the Muslims so the
zionists were harassing the Palestinians
preparing to drive them from their homes
announcing that they wanted to build a
state where the Arabs wouldn't exist
they were saying that they were prepared
to go to Great l in order to achieve
this and in this context they were
saying give us a state or we will kill
you 1948 or 1947 un says let's partition
let's put into context it's true they
said let's partition and the Arabs
rejected it let's put into context the
UN was saying Guys these zionists really
want to take your land they want to take
your homes they're prepared to use Force
they're prepared to kill you for it
they're prepared to to drive you we
don't really want to stop these people
from committing the Injustice we want to
legitimize the theft of land and we'd
like you to agree to acknowledge the
theft of land we'd like you to agree to
the Injustice we'd like you to accept it
and swallow it we'd like you to say yes
please take my home we'd like you to say
yes please take my land we'd like to say
yes we're going to leave and we're going
to give it to you for no other reason
than you have violence and guns and the
like and they're presenting this offer
that look we want to do this nicely we
want to take your land nicely we want to
kick you out nicely we want to seize
this and make this state exclusive for
us we want to do it nicely and we're
offering you a chance give us your home
or we will kill you what a Wonderful
Merciful offer that was Eddie and then
the Arabs decided to invade when the
zionists go out and kick out the
Palestinians from their home when the
zionists Go and Kill the Palestinians
when they Turf them from their land
something that is illegal under every
legal code on this Earth even here in
the United States of America if someone
enters your land without permission you
guys have arms here I've seen you guys
with your gun and guns in your glove
boxes something that coming from London
it's quite horrific to see although
somebody did respond and say you have
stabbings in London I'm like okay fine I
get it but still to see guns there so
easy in the US law you have it if
someone enters your land without
permission and refuses to leave what do
you do Eddie you you are allowed legally
to shoot him it's a very strange thing
for me but I mean under every legal code
this is absolutely outrageous she's
right when she says that they proposed
the state for the Palestinians but why
did they propose a state because they
wanted Palestinians to say do take give
us the land or we'll kill you and when
they proceeded to kill the Palestinians
and take the land the Arab States
invaded so she's right the UN offered
partition the Arab states rejected it
and invaded she's told the half truth
yeah let let's finish the full truth
let's finish all of it let's talk about
why it was offered let's talk about why
the Arab States invaded let's talk about
why they invaded in a way that the US
would invade a country if another
country like Russia invaded Ukraine in
order to drive the ukrainians out of
their homes let's talk about why they
invaded in a way that the European
States would invade in order to rescue
one of their allies if their allies were
invaded by a foreign entity that came in
and tried to take their homes and their
land let's talk about 1967 they provided
a a peace agreement and the Arabs broke
it what peace agreement a peace
agreement in which you were trying to
say to the Palestinians okay in 1947 or
1948 we took this bit of land now we
want this bit of land and we're giving
you the same offer again we're ready to
kill you our arms are ready our guns are
loaded we are coming in we're coming in
we're giving you a chance sign this deal
handing it over or we're coming to kill
you and when we talk about the Oslo
Accords same thing now we've got this
much land it's getting bigger now this
this state of Israel taking more land
Israel makes the same offer again she's
perfectly correct they made the offer
for a Palestinian State what was that
offer the offer was we're coming for you
our guns are loaded we want your lands
we're going to kick out your house we're
coming we're coming Jin Jin we're coming
we're coming we're giving you a choice
Choice do you want to do this peacefully
or do you want us to kill you we want
you to leave your homes because we
believe we have a thousand- year old
claim to that par we don't care you've
lived there hundreds of years we don't
care you lived all your life there we
don't care the land belongs to you we
don't care under UK law it belongs to
you we don't care that under us law it
would belong to you we don't care under
every legal code it would belong to you
we want it because we are the chosen
people we're coming to kill you for it
so we're making you an offer which are
the osow ACC cords give us the land give
us the security apparatus all we will
kill you 2005 they withdraw from Gazza
she says golden opportunity to build a
resort in a wonderful piece of land so
Subhan Allah you Turf the Palestinians
from all of the rest of the territory
and you put 2 million people in what
David Cameron the former UK prime
minister described as the largest open
air prison and then you're saying to
them look it's a wonderful opportunity
yes it's a prison yes it's a
concentration camp concentration
concentration of people in a camp yes
we've squeezed you yes we've taken your
homes but we're we're trying to be nice
Here Eddie yes we slaughtered your
family yes we're taking your land by
force yes we've committed ethnic
cleansing yes we are building an
apartheid state yes you have to go
through six different checkpoints just
to get to work yes we believe you to be
inferior yes you don't have equal rights
yes we believe in that yes we do all of
this but we're being nice Here Eddie
we're giving you a chance to establish a
state we're coming we're coming with our
guns so you have to decide do you want
us to kill you or will you leave
peacefully and give me that wonderful
Villa that your grandfather built that I
want to live in why because in Brooklyn
my flat is too small so I will the
Israel told me I could move here and
Jacob says if I don't steal it somebody
else will and that's the point that I
want to make here everything she says is
correct but she doesn't finish the truth
because if she finishes it it condemns
her if she finish it it indicts her and
we have a saying in Islam there is a
Ayah in the Quran which
says if you finish it halfway this is
one of the only verses where you're not
allowed to stop in the middle because it
gives the wrong
meaning do not approach prayer if you
stop the a there it means don't pray you
have to finish the a in order to
understand the
context and you if you are intoxicated
she's
done finish the the rest of the context
and that's why I think that sometimes
even to that verse you keep going
because you're not even supposed to be
drinking at all exactly even that verse
you keep going and that's why I think
that even when you look at that spin
this is why it's very important this is
why if you look at a lot of the way dawa
is given it's given in the sense of a
rhetoric and speech and to use speech
which is best because Allah acknowledges
that that kind of speech sounds
reasonable to somebody who doesn't know
about the issue and that's why it's
incumbent on us in order to give the
context nobody said Muslims and Jews
shouldn't live side by side and we spent
a long time in the beginning of this
podcast talking about why but she wants
to neglect it to give a half truth to
say yes we offered these suggestions but
on what basis did you offer these
suggestions and she will never talk
about that because will condemn her and
give the real truth of the matter uh
Professor Norman felstein when I
interviewed him and he touches upon the
point that they always looked they
always the Palestinians always worked
towards going towards peace but they
always would set these things up as a
sabotage they always try to to make
these things there's one context they
give for the public but then they're on
the side they're sabotaging these things
from happening oh no of course 100% And
I think one of the things that's quite
fascinating is net they really don't
want it they just want to
be given an excuse a pretext to go ahead
and take more land but to give general
public the idea that they're looking and
striving for peace but they really the
intention is not peace at all one of the
things there are two things worth noting
one Netanyahu always says in the Hebrew
media that I am the reason that prevents
a Palestinian State I have refused and
rejected all the two-state solutions yes
I say it in public but that's only to
provide the cover for us to continue
doing what we're doing and that's why I
always argue that the reason I am
against the two-state solution in every
single way is because the two-state
solution as it's being proposed is
merely an umbrella through which to
prolong negotiations and prolong a
window through which Israel continues to
take more and more land and I believe
that the two-state solution is merely a
ploy that is deployed in order to allow
Israel more time to Annex more
territories in the hope as Netanyahu
proposed at the UN one week before
October 7th that he can wipe out
Palestine from the river to the Sea and
make it all just one state of Israel in
which the Palestinians are second class
citizens as Mark regev the former
spokesman said on Sky News he said they
must always remain an inferior people
they can never have equal rights to us
the two the reason that the Palestine
issue offends the very sensibilities of
non-muslims as well is because the fitra
is screaming at the glaring reality
which is that while the world can see
apartheid now taking place Human Rights
Watch and Amnesty International are
using the words apartheid to describe
Israel that while the world sees that
there is an apartheid regime that is set
on persecuting and denying the rights of
the Palestinians the reaction of the
world is not to uphold their own law
which is to restore the rights of the
people instead you see this
horrifying legal terminology being
deployed in which they say we don't want
to restore the rights of the
Palestinians we want to discuss how much
theft we can legalize under the pretext
of the two-state solution so the
discussion is not about right of return
the discussion is look these guys have
already taken land we have no interest
in restoring Justice in restoring
Palestinians to those lands instead we
want to discuss to what extent are
Palestinians willing to accept the theft
of the land so okay they've stolen this
much land can we say you know you accept
this much or you AC that's what
two-state solution is about it's not
Justice it's we've stolen the land and
we have no interest in restoring that
Justice your choice is not Justice your
choice is to decide how much land you
were willing to swallow and accept has
been stolen and that's why the two-state
solution is unjust in its very premise
in and of itself and also why talking
about the future instead of the past
it's also why the Israelis are panicking
that there is a debate taking place in
America and in their former allies over
the legitimacy of the foundations of the
state of Israel Eddie you saw the sky
news interview with the UK with the
Israeli ambassador to the UK where he
asks her three times is there do you
believe in a two-state solution and she
doesn't answer and then she eventually
says no but you saw the horror on the
face of the presenter now we've always
we've always known this but look how for
them it's like a wakeup call he looks at
he says what what do you mean like he's
absolutely horrified and stunned why
because in her answer she has revealed
to him face to face that I don't want
equal rights for the Palestinians I
don't want Palestinians to have a state
and I don't see a role for them for
Israel itself and think about it one of
the things that has come out and why I
called it the Great Awakening 3 months
ago Eddie if you had done a show here
questioning the foundations of the
Israeli State none one in America would
have probably taken you seriously or
taken any of us seriously now the very
allies of the US this is why in the hill
there was an article by Zionist writer
where he writes in the conclusion that
while Netanyahu may win the military
battle the damage to public opinion is
such that our allies May no longer rush
to our help in future as a result of the
damage that has been done today people
are not talking about whether you know a
part or like people are now questioning
the very nature of the Israeli State the
ethnocentric nature of the Israeli state
so that's the point with regards to a
two-state solution or the like the idea
that they have sabotaged it because
their aim is not rights for Palestinians
their aim is the genocide of
Palestinians and adopting a marketing
strategy that makes it look Humane and
merciful and that marketing strategy is
the two-state solution you mentioned
this term apar tide I don't think
anybody now if they look back at South
Africa anybody at this point would try
to uh reason and say yeah we' supported
that we support that everybody's it's
clear it's clear that this was something
evil was something horrific it was
something racist now you have this term
being used for for the state Israel
let's just touch upon this so you
mentioned you have human rights
organizations even Israeli is it true
that Israeli human rights organizations
that label it an aparti State Jimmy
Carter did Nelson Mandela is this clear
and how can someone now who supports
this doesn't support the partti South
Africa but now human rights organization
former president I mean this is Nelson
Mandela people who experts in this area
of law they're saying this is an partied
state so how can someone support it and
would you question their humanity and
them not being racist if to support some
even Jews uh Jewish rabbis and others
you know will come out you know against
say we have one set of laws for us
another set of law for for um non-jews
you can't go down the street if you're
not a Jew touch upon this I think that
one the reason this phenomenon is
emerging recently and didn't emerge 70
years ago is because there is a
phenomenon that I celebrate
wholeheartedly which is social media and
I celebrate social media and I know that
there are many problems with social
media but social media broke and this
broke the Monopoly on the narrative and
also decentralized information I
understand that it promotes fake news
from time to time but the
decentralization of information gives us
access to information that we did not
have access to before the reason why
apartheid is now being being used in
mainstream discourse is because those
Brave Palestinians those courageous
Palestinians recorded their daily life
they recorded the checkpoints they
broadcasted the reality they broadcasted
the atrocities they broadcasted the
crimes that Israel is committing they
broadcast the apartheid state in such a
way and everybody Amplified their voices
and algorithm only only likes popular
videos so when 1.9 billion Muslims
amplifying those videos for the
Palestinians it breaks the algorithm it
makes it instead of Christiano Ronaldo
at number one it makes it you know I
know America don't like soccer terms but
instead of Tom Brady you guys have here
I think or something yeah instead of Tom
Brady being number one you now have
Palestine 1 2 3 4 on the list of the
social media of what they're seeing when
people saw that it became undeniably
they had heard about apartheid but when
you hear something you might doubt it
this time they saw it and that has led
to the change in rhetoric with regards
to aparti there is one particular
account which is very interesting where
she records her commute to work which in
terms of kilometers it only takes 10
minutes to get there but as a result of
the checkpoints it takes her 3 hours
every morning to get there at 5:00 a.m.
in the morning she has to wake up and
all when she records that when American
professors are now going to Gaza or
going to the west bank and then their
Muslim guide says you can go there I'll
meet you on the other side and the
professor says why why aren't you going
with me and they say legally I'm not
allowed to walk on this particular
Street and he's horrified and he comes
back to the US and does an interview on
democracy now and on CNN and say I went
to the the West Bank and I saw with my
own eyes that these people can't even
walk streets and as a black man this
reminded me very similar to what America
used to be like that social media has
broken that hold and resulted in people
using the word apartheid and the like
not only that as a result of
Representatives in Congress I understand
they're very controversial I understand
many people have many issues with them
such as Rashid andan Omar or the like
I'm not interested in that debate today
I'm focusing on something that they've
done which has been spectacularly good
which is that in Congress
they delivered that language to the
Congress floor they stood up and used
the word apartheid for the first time in
the history of the Congress they stood
up and called it a genocide for the
first time in congress's history not
only that I remember when they censored
Rashid which was 250 votes something 292
and many people are like look Congress
is still standing with Israel they
censored her 250 votes 292 and I turned
and I said but guys have you ever seen
192 Congress people defy the Zionist
line have you ever seen 192 Congress
people betray the Israeli line have you
ever seen 100 nights the point is you
can see that Israel is losing its
ability to influence when I see a
Zionist girl in La I saw the Tik Tok
video recently Tik Tok which I know many
people have problems with but I can't
lie to you after this thing Eddie may
Allah preserve and protect Tik Tok for
us as a means of communication you know
and my algorithm alhamdulillah is all
soccer games and Islamic reminders and
whatever it's amazing how you can fix
the algorithm to make your own bubble
but the reason I mentioned the bubble is
look how loud the Palestinian cause is
that even in my algorithm bubble even in
the algorithm bubbles Palestine is
penetrating those bubbles Tik Tok was
supposed to create a world where only
you live in it pales the Roar for
festine has been so loud Eddie that
everybody's bubble in social media has
been penetrated by the Palestinian
voices so much so that I saw a video of
a girl in La do a video where she says
I'm not going to try the accent cuz I
can't do it but she said I lived all my
life in a Zionist environment she said I
lived in La I never heard Palestinian
voices Tik Tok brought Palestinian
voices and I can't unsee what I've seen
and as a result she says I'm going to do
a video every single day exposing what
Israel is doing to the palestin that's
unprecedented that's unprecedented and
that's what I mean but at the heart of
this change is not necessarily A an
Awakening of conscience that came by
itself it's that the bombardment of the
information coming out of Palestine and
the decentralization of the medium that
people were using to receive their news
where people now I mean I don't know
about you but I receive my news every
morning I don't go on bbc.co.uk I go on
Twitter and I look and I see the
headlines what people are saying you
know real real news kind of that's where
everybody's getting their information
from or on some people in the night time
they watch Tik Tok and they see the
videos but the point is that
decentralization of information has
resulted in an unprecedented
accessibility to information that Israel
was trying to hide Israel was always
putting this hijab this sort of you know
block you know between the access to the
P that's emphatically broken and in this
environment of freedom of free speech
the irony in this environment of Freedom
Israel's arguments are collapsing one by
one to the extent that Biden here is
falling in the polls here in the US is
falling in the polls and I read the
Reuters article and you probably read it
as well I the Republic and Democrat
pollsters who analyzed this poll said
the reason that poll is extraordinary is
is is because of two things the
first it's not just the economy that is
resulting in the fall in the polls they
said his stance on festine is resulting
in the fall in the polls but the second
and more extraordinary thing is is that
the polls he's falling in the polls over
a foreign policy issue where America
doesn't even officially have troops on
the ground usually the reason a war
affects the polls is because Americans
get tired of their boys dying abroad
this is UN this is one of the first
times ever where probably the first time
ever where American boys are not dying
in a conflict abroad but still that
conflict is resulting in a fall in the
PO which means the only reason Biden is
falling in the polls is because the
breaking of the Monopoly of the
narrative by social media has meant that
for the first time the information is
spreading in unprecedented ways and
that's why more people are using the
word apartheid that's why they're using
the word genocide that's why they're
using the word ethnic cleansing that's
why they're calling genocide Joe and
it's also and I finish on this point I
asked some friends in France why did
macron call for a ceasefire and they
said literally I I this is literally
what they said they said macron it's not
that he believes in it is that
everywhere he went in France he just
kept hearing people saying mus your pron
please cease fire now and he got so
frustrated and that he just said okay
I'll give a speech cease fire but Israel
has the right to self-defense the media
only for focused on ceasefire cuz that's
what the social media seized upon and
that has sparked and encouraged the
momentum calling for a ceasefire as well
it's social media and I always I make a
semi joke although it's it's probably
more serious than it is joking may Allah
bless and guide the creators of social
media who broke that Monopoly on the
narrative and allowed us to deliver our
voices in this way uh there's a few more
um talking points that
are po they're very popular out there
and they constantly um on the social on
the on the um news networks they're
always pushing this uh I think you
answer this one in the reaction to the
pbd podcast guest but um if you can
answer outside of this one uh why so
they'll say that well they pulled out in
2006 was it that they pulled out and
they could have made this uh they could
have had Trump Towers there they could
have had a nice theme park they could
have made it Paradise on Earth they left
they pulled out how can they be occupied
if they pulled out how would you address
that one of the reasons that the
Israelis pulled out was because they
were consented that there was a real
push for a two-state solution amongst
the International Community so they
wanted to give some sort of breathing
space for the Palestinians whereby they
could deny them a two-state solution the
idea being is that we sort of make a
semi compromise in order to ensure that
the two-state solution cannot come about
and also we squeeze them in that Gaza
Strip so that there will always be a hot
bed that will always allow us to ruin
the idea of a two-state solution and
that's why allies in 2015 when CC really
wanted to demonstrate an affinity for
Israel and began to really shut the
tunnels under the ra Crossing Wall
Street Journal reported that the
Israelis told the Americans CCE is way
too OV excited in his persecution of the
Palestinians please tell him to calm
down otherwise he's going to lead into a
lashing out and that will force us into
negotiations over a two-state solution
again in order to bring that
deescalation down I think that when they
withdrew from Gazza it was not about
trying to facilitate freedom for
Palestinians it was about trying to
prolong the idea of a two-state solution
because that's the umbrella through
which they were hoping to Annex the rest
of of Palestine and not only that after
they withdrew from Gaza their focus on
the West Bank so they withdrew from
Gazza and went and started raiding genor
refugee camp they withdrew from Gazza
and went and started attacking the West
Bank they was sort of like a shifting of
priorities it was like okay we'll give
this to Gazza for now in order to buy
time for us to go and conquer the West
Bank and that's why I think that actions
speak louder than words when it comes to
what Israel is doing yeah the uh Rabbi
one Rabbi he U gave a beautiful example
he said that they pulled out it's saying
like the the people with control the
guards of the prison they just went home
but they still have control over the
prison the people who are in the prison
and they just sort of expanded the
prison and that's why one of the things
is that is that right so they're
controlling their air their water their
calorie count the list goes on they
blockaded it they don't have access to
the Sea they can't import they can't
they control everything permits if they
want to build a house build a home they
can't do they make everything just IM
bearable impossible and that's why
Franchesca albanesi I hope I pronounced
her name right the the the UN repor she
said you know she quite bluntly she said
under Le legal
definition Israel may have withdrawn
from Gaza but it is still the occupier
in every single legal sense this is
according to now this is to
international law international law so
the UN also acknowledges acknowledges
this is an occupation that's why got a
partti acknowledge we got no Shadow of
Doubt left this is according to
international law and experts this is an
occupation this is an occupation by
every legal term even under
international law and that's why the
point was made that you know the reason
Israel Al doesn't have a right to
self-defense is because an occupier is
always in an offensive posture and
therefore cannot defend itself against
an occupied people even in international
law and that's why even little details
tend to go under the radar when they're
pushing context like the video you
showed me earlier in that for even the
party that was taking place you know on
October 7th just outside and for the
record and it's important to highlight
here Muslims do not shy away from
condemning crimes that are committed by
Muslims by that what I mean is Muslims
condemn civilian deaths regardless of
who commits it and I give an Islamic
example
when was sent by the prophet Muhammad s
alhi was to a particular tribe reports
reached him that khed had transgressed
against some of the population of that
tribe and the prophet is on record as
saying
Allah Allah I am innocent of what has
done we have a tradition in Islam
whereby we don't Sher away from saying
things like we condemn the death of
civilians that's not something that's
hard for a Muslim to say it's easy to
say without undermining the resistance
or undermining the rights of the
Palestinians or the like the reason why
I say that is that to to the point is
when you think about it and I want to
put this in the minds of those who are
watching this there was a party taking
place on October 7th where on the border
of what's described as the largest open
air prison in the world think about that
A persecuted population in the largest
concentration camp and you're raving and
parting at the walls of that
concentration camp that's that's insane
when you think about it you know like
it's you know it's it's like the Germans
you know doing a rave next to aitz for
example you know like
like it's it's even when you think about
the way that we have become desensitized
to the way we talk about this issue
which thankfully social media has helped
to remedy some of it that even the
sentence of there was a party next to
the walls of this concentration camp
didn't evoke the outrage it was supposed
to evoke in the first place and that's
why even in the point of Gaza the
Israelis withdrew but okay they withdrew
in name only in de facto Tams they
essentially control everything in the
Gaza Strip yeah uh what about the common
argument you know I think it was the
hospitals that are being bombed schools
are being bombed un facilities but the
excuse is always human Shields how do
you like to address this I think bessim
YF you know bessim YF had a phenomenal
interview with P
Morgan and while you know you know many
people hesitated because he played an
integral role in facilitating the coup
in Egypt that led to the toppling of the
democratic transition there we leave
that as a separate topic but I I say
that to show that still I acknowledge
and appreciate that P Morgan interview
where he gave that very personal example
where he said he called his in-law that
was in Gaza and he said you know ah ham
you know telling you you can't leave
Gaza because they want to use as a human
shield and he said no they're not we
just can't leave because of Israeli
bombing and Bess a joke he says you're
lying you're lying Ben shapir Ronda
santis are telling me that Hamas is
telling you you can't leave basically
showing how ridiculous it is that the
person on the ground is telling you no
they're not we just can't leave because
of the bombs and somebody thousands and
thousands of miles away saying no
they're using them as human Shields and
I think that the argument of the human
shelds what it did more than anything
else is is expose the semantic
gymnastics that analysts are willing to
do to justify and give Nuance to
genocide in ethnic cleansing that is
unfolding before their eyes CU on the
one hand you're saying that this is the
most sophisticated army in the world
that is capable of surgical strikes that
is capable of PR strikes or the like but
yet you see 400 people killed in a bomb
of the jabalia refugee camp you see for
example like hundreds of people being
killed women and children and theal this
isn't surgical Precision strike this is
Hab this is you're just bombing
everywhere Left Right Center which
suggests either you're trying to commit
genocide or ethnic cleansing or either
your army is quite pathetic in capable
of surgical strikes and you don't you're
not as great as you think they are
you're condemned in in in either way and
that's why I think the issue of the
human Shields as well even when you
think about it you've got 2 million
people in a very small stretch of land
that you have turfed from other areas
and you forced them into refugee camps
where are those people supposed to go
you haven't allowed them to go anywhere
else so you don't want to allow them to
go to their homes you don't want to get
let them return to their lands you don't
want to give them equal rights you don't
want a one state solution you want to
take more of their land you've got their
eyes on the jine refugee camp you want
your aim is to take all of their land
like what what exactly do you want you
know really uh one um the uh Norman
flein been studying this for 40 years he
talks about how it's the opposite when
he read all the reports from Amnesty
International all the human rights inter
organizations he said it's actually the
the IDF they're using the Palestinians
as human Shields there it's actually
flipped it's not it's not that the P the
that uh this is actually a false
statement it's the other way around
no and I I agree entirely and and I
think norstein you know he has a
wonderful way like in the way in the way
he uses his words to expose the
hypocrisy and and also like
he one of the reasons that I think his
phenomenon is quite fascinating is to
have somebody whose parents suffered in
the Holocaust in the Holocaust they
suffered on the Holocaust but he still
has the capacity and the empathy to be
able to see similarities with what's
unfolding with regards to the
Palestinians but also it's the
understanding that he demonstrates that
suggests that many Jews demonstrate as
well when he gave that answer in the P
Morgan interview at the end where he
said you know what would your parents
say if they heard your stance and he
said look my parents did not have a good
word to say about the Germans for their
entirety of their lives and he said I
understood that after what the Germans
did to them and he said that's why I
understand like that the Palestinians
have the right to hate the people who
Turf them from their land who Turf them
from their homes who slaughtered their
families for no other reason than a
people turned up claiming to have a
chosen right to him to be a chosen
people with the rights to the land and
suddenly decided to Turf people who'd
Liv there for hundreds of years they
have every right to hate people who
persecuted them for no reason who
slaughtered them for no reason who took
their lands for no reason it's a
perfectly legitimate reaction and that's
why I argue that one of the things even
with October 7th bear in mind October
7th was not a surprise for many people
is netan was warned even by CeCe and by
others that your approach to trampling
on the Palestinians for nor will lead to
an explosion it was a consequence of the
actions everybody knew it was coming
it's not about whether it was right or
wrong it's a it's a natural reaction
it's look there's a pressure cooker
pressure cooker that is going to explode
and the world is trying to say it
doesn't explode do you think uh some it
just brought this to my mind do you
think some are saying that he allowed
this to happen to use it as a c as a
pretext to do what he's doing now I
don't think so I I think that to be
honest I think that Netanyahu was lulled
into a false sense of security because
the week before yeah he had given that
speech in the UN where he said that you
know he presented that map that had
completely erased but he also said that
normalization of ties with Saudi Arabia
would be the greatest deal since the end
of the Cold War he also sat with erdogan
for the first time since erdogan came to
power in 2003 and I remember the
Israelis were really showing off their
image herey herey look look look erdogan
is sitting with because erdogan wants
that gas pipeline in in the Eastern
Mediterranean and he's worried about the
Middle East Corridor that might bypass
turkey when when netan came even the UAE
Ambassador in the US 3 months ago I
think he was talking with Carnegie or
Brooking and they said and Brookings and
they said to him you know has
normalization achieved anything for the
Palestinians and he said you know we
haven't achieved anything with regards
to normalization we haven't achieved
anything for the Palestinians but we
haven't achieved anything for the
Palestinians but he
said you know it's now on the future
states that normalize to try to secure
something for the Palestinians but that
won't make us you know reverse
normalization because look at the trade
deals we've signed look at how many
flights between Tel Aviv and Abu Dhabi
essentially even the Israeli assador to
the UN just to emphasize how much net
was led into for sense of security when
you look at the Israeli ambassador to
the UN he told K television just the
week before October 7th he said that the
normalization with Saudi Arabia he said
in his words quote means the complete
Arab abandonment of the Palestinians and
when the government sees the
opportunities that presents they will
sign off on the normalization by
opportunities what he meant was he meant
the military buildup in that week on the
border with with the Janine refugee camp
as the Israelis were preparing to Annex
the Janine refugee camp the point is
Netanyahu believed that in 2019 when he
wanted to Annex the Janine refugee camp
he had to stop because Trump told him we
want UAE to normalize so delay it and
then when he was preparing again six
months later he was toppled from Power
then naali Bennett tried to Annex janim
but he failed because they killed
the the journalist so that heavy
pressure meant they had to withdraw and
stop the the The Invasion now Netanyahu
is back and he wants to Annex the J
refugee camp again and that's on the
West Bank we've seen so many attacks
like there's no Hamas in the West Bank
but there's still attack in the West
Bank because the aim is to go and Annex
that West Bank the point here being is
that I don't I think netan was genuinely
taken by surprise I think he's actually
fighting for his political future I
think that after this is finished he's
most likely to be kicked out of power I
think the reason the war is being
prolonged is because while everybody
including the Americans are saying
there's really no strategic aim you can
achieve here like this is hard it looks
netan is the one who knows if he stops
now he will be kicked out of power
because everybody's turning against him
huge protest in Tel Aviv you mentioned
him earlier yid and these others are all
coming out asking him to to step down
from Power he was taken by surprise
because he was hoping to begin an
invasion of Janine but was hit from
behind by I like what you said earlier
that we have no problem because Islam
calls us to be just God Almighty the
Creator tells us in the Quran also that
if uh a fic if untrustworthy person
comes to you you so on one end no
problem condemning killing of innocent
people no problem we have no problem
with that if it's proven to be true no
problem on the other end we have a clear
verse from the verbatim word of God
Almighty Allah the Creator saying that
if a untrustworthy person comes to you
with news verify it check it out uh so
we have an untrustworthy Source coming
to us known to lie over and over and
over so when you look at this this event
and you see independent journalists who
are investigating this and they're
showing that um there was a henal
directive I don't know if you've heard
of this turn henal
[Applause]
[Music]
directive
[Applause]
[Music]
for
fore
[Applause]
[Music]
spe
foree
[Applause]
[Music]
spee
fore
spe
for
they're showing that um interviews with
generals and commanders in the Army and
they're showing how you had Apache elev
uh Apache helicopters and they were told
uh empty the belly and they would just
just destroyed everything in sight and
then you had tanks also coming and
destroying everything and then this
caused burning and this caused you you
know annihilation of everything in sight
so what do you have to say about this
you know and a lot of these things
kicked off the 40 beheaded babies and it
was pushed by the media these rapes and
all this other stuff that you're like
hold on it's like someone telling you
that uh someone who's known to be an
extreme like vegan right that he's
eating bodies he's eating meat now right
so this is something that's totally
opposite to Islam rape killing innocent
human beings so you're naturally you're
going to be kind of you know sensitive
to be like hold on uh yeah in one end we
condemn any of these act it's horrific
horrific all human life is precious but
on the other hand you're stuck here
between the whole mass media and they're
pushing all these things but then when
you look to it you have a few
independent journalists who are really
doing what journalists supposed to do
they're uncovering facts that most
people they they're not digging a little
deeper and seeing what do you think
about this I think we first of all we
can add one extra aah to to the Justice
which
is do not let and the linguistic can
suggest double meaning so do not let
your hatred over a people or their
hatred of you lead you to be unjust be
just this is closer to truth before you
go deeper I want to add to this and then
you have also uncovered you have a lot
of some of these organizations who are
pushing this out I forgot what they're
they're called these stories are coming
from disaster relief groups that are
fighting for media attention and
charitable donations these groups are in
the business of raising money and right
now atrocity fundraising is a gold rush
very wealthy and very emotional Jewish
westerners are opening up their wallets
to organizations and Charities and these
organizations are jockeying for position
as the best charity to give money to and
nothing raises money like a good story
for example Eli beer the president of
United hatzala went on a media tour
around the United States telling
audiences that babies were placed in
ovens and baked to death a little baby
in an oven they put him in these
bastards put these baby in an oven and
put on the oven we found the kid a few
hours later this propelled him and his
organization to the Forefront of the
media for several days earning tons of
awareness for his organization's work he
was able to leverage this media
attention into several fundraisers where
he managed to collect a whopping $50
million from shocked and appalled donors
but of course the entire story was a lie
Israeli reporter isay Cohen investigated
and Det determined that the story wasn't
true another Israeli journalist K Lenin
said had this to say about Eli beer and
the of in story like any good
Jew who sees the rich he thought about
the money and told a story that does not
exist but this lie not only raised a ton
of money for Eli beer it did
considerable damage to the ceasefire
movement and cost thousands of
Palestinian children their lives these
uh organizations that are out there uh
they're actually getting money
collecting money from pushing many of
these Liv see there is a sort of Race To
The Bottom taking place right now
between competing Israeli disaster
relief groups it's a competition to see
who can tell the most disturbing story
United hatah isn't alone in doing this
they have a competitor in the disaster
relief space called zaka and this group
zaka is responsible for some of the most
obscene atrocity imaginations these
people lied about beheaded babies they
lied about Mass rape they even lied
about a fetus being cut out of its
mother and just like United hso zaka is
hungry for money right now go ahead one
of the things that is worth noting one
of the the biggest thing that Israel is
concerned about is not that the
Palestinians can secure military Victory
but that the Palestinians would be
humanized yeah if you remember in the
first part of the in the first week Al
jaaz a video where they showed
Palestinians there's a woman frightened
holding her baby and the Palestinians
are
shouting cover her cover her you know
show her that we have a Humanity that
the partied regime lacks on channel 12
the Israeli Channel when they
interviewed somebody who was one of in
one of the settlements one of the
settlers she said what they asked her
what was the experience like and she
said yeah when they came in we were
scared but then he says to me I'm not
here to harm you I'm Muslim and and her
her literal reaction Ed is
I was a bit surprised but I felt relaxed
and they're like what did they do what
did they do they walked around my house
for 2 hours he asked me if he could have
a banana I said yes and he left Israel
was deeply concerned about these stories
that were coming out not from Muslim
media but from Israelis themselves they
were deeply concerned that there was
sudden a humanization that was taking
place of the Palestinians which is why
they sent that I24 reporter to come out
and begin the story of the beheaded
babies even though you would think that
if there was a store beheaded babies the
Israelis would not hesitate to provide
proof but they didn't and what made
things even worse for her was that the
IDF when they were asked they said we
haven't seen any evidence of beheaded
babies the IDF themselves said it but
the I I24 still went on with it and CNN
did 24-hour wall-to-wall coverage on the
issue of the beheaded babies when social
media demanded proof when they demanded
proof when they demanded that the
evidence be given for this issue of
beheaded babies and social media was
rled where's the proof even I remember
Bel TR one of the journalists she
reported on it she tried to take the
caveat to say look I haven't seen
evidence but but she was lambasted for
even regurgitating it because the
independent ran it with it on the front
page and put beheaded between quotation
marks as if to say legally we're not
saying we saw it but the but the damage
was done we know what media is like you
put the image out like that's it because
they were unable to provide proof and
evidence eventually now nobody's talking
about the beheaded babies anymore like
even when Biden said in the White House
when Biden said I've seen the pictures
the White House came out and said the
day after Biden hadn't seen those
pictures they they denied Biden because
even those staff in the White House
realized that guys let's be serious it's
coming from Israel like we know what
they like we know they lie through their
teeth like it's not you know you know
their own people were testifying against
them did did they uncover with the shaah
hospital they were saying someone was
under then they and they got disproved
even though Biden said I've seen
evidence there is a command sent under
shifa hospital they did sha hospital
they didn't find it underneath but
there's a reason why they're getting
debunked and this is the point I wanted
to make here the reason they're getting
debunked is not because Biden and
Netanyahu are calling these news
journalists and telling them please
uphold journalistic Integrity it's
because on social media it's so loud the
demand for proof is so loud when you
I've I've never seen journalists
apologize for their coverage of
Palestine and Israel I've never seen
journalists apologize and you I don't
think you've seen it either mallah I
assume you're young man still but older
than me certainly but you I you've
probably never seen it either the point
being is why did they apologize they
didn't apologize because they got
protest from the Israeli Embassy they
apologized because there was such a loud
denouncement of the poor journalistic
Integrity online that meant that they
felt they had to come out to apologize
to push back against that we are the
ones with our loud voices forcing them
to at least consider returning to that
journalistic Integrity even Clarissa
Ward on CNN some of her reporting was
was horrific the bomb would be like
miles away and then she did this whole
thing where she went on the floor and
she went oh I can hear the bombs and
then you look at the Palestinians in
Gaza a bomb comes and they're doing an
interview and they go and they continue
giving the interview so Clarissa you're
miles away they're within the vicinity
of the bombs why do you react this way
for in order to give you know some sort
of exaggerated response in order to
create some hysteria whereas the
Palestinians who are there giving the
interviews are not reacting the way that
you reacted and the point is that
eventually cariss award when you look at
the latest report of CNN going into Gaza
when they went in it's markedly
different from how she was reporting
before and that's because of the
pressure that was placed on CNN as a
result of the public backlash over their
failure to uphold journalistic Integrity
in looking at looking deeply into the
allegations that are being made by the
Israelis and if you noce today Israel is
still pushing out accusations but none
of them gain traction anymore even the
rape Hillary Clinton came out to help
with that PR campaign she came out and
said you don't know what hams is like
and they commit the rape but even
Hillary
Clinton that momentum I haven't heard
that statement being made now about the
rape at least for the past week or so
it's been debunked because they all said
it but and the reason why there's a dram
quesi from cage in the UK made a very
good point when I read on Twitter he
said the reason why is that Israel is
telling us what's happening but the
Palestinians are showing us what's
happening they're telling us but these
arees are showing us that's the
difference this time you're actually
seeing uh the beheaded babies from the
bombs and exactly so you're saying okay
Israel is saying they are beheaded
babies but they haven't showed us a
single image Palestinians are showing
you mutilated baby there was a
video there was a
video of a man saying he had the bag and
he's collecting the limbs of his
children like the limbs he said I can't
find the arm he said has anybody he's
he's the limbs of his children and
you're seeing cuz he holds the bag and
he's like you're see seeing it with your
own eyes and the other reason that's
really hitting the Israeli propaganda
really hard is and you would have seen
this interview CU it came last week they
asked the hostages how were you treated
and she said they played card with us
they said they taught one of our kids
like you know like like like a new skill
they they they ate food with us they
were very friendly with us they were you
somebody said the that the Israeli
hostages have Stockholm syndrome you
know like for example the two old ladies
in the beginning when they were released
and they turned around they said Shalom
alayum you know and Shake shook hands
with them all the other ones you know
like they were smiling you know one one
one you know like that to her to her
host to to to to the fighters you know
to to say you know as if it was a
pleasant experience and they said the
these people have Stockholm syndrome and
I saw a lovely response they said okay
let's suppose it's Stockholm syndrome
why don't any of the Palestinian
prisoners being released by Israel have
stockh home syndrome why are all the
Palestinian prisoners being released
from Israel they come out in a headlock
or they come out you know with their
collors being dragged why is it every
Israeli hostage has Stockholm syndrome
but not a single Palestinian prisoner
has Stockholm syndrome and that's what
making them Panic with the pr in that
for the first time since 1948 the media
is struggling to uphold The Narrative
that Palestinians are not human and for
the first time people are seeing
Palestinian and that is an unprecedented
and permanent change there there's a lot
tell Pac we're almost out of time but
you reminded me that's a whole different
topic you know the thousands how many
kids are being held without charge in uh
maximum security prisons out there it's
like uh unbelievable we started with
this former congresswoman and I want
people to just replaced the term that
she's using imagine if this is this is
the kind of the rhetoric that at the
time when people were trying were
committing a holocaust this this evil
acts that we condemn this is something
evil and then they were they were
fleeing to Muslim lands as you uh
explained in the beginning if how would
you interpret as we started with this
woman we'll end here uh the words that
she's using and I want this to stick
with people tomorrow that because she
was a former Congress per she has a big
responsibility a big platform she's also
the dean of Christian uh college now so
um are these the leaders that we want
representing us I ask our our friends
and and um neighbors out there and I
want you to let me know how would you
interpret these words it's time that
Gaza ends the two million people who
live there they are clever assassins
they need to be removed from that land
that land needs to be turned into a
national park you see why I give a
little intro to that so just how do you
I mean see I mean it seems like it's
inciting isn't that you you've studied
some national international law is isn't
I mean um it seems like this is um
inciting genocide not just inciting
genocide doesn't it's inciting genocide
it's inci and not only that and look I
show deep respect to victims and I don't
like to politically play with the
Holocaust or the suffering of the Jews
under the Nazi Germany it was horrific
by every stretch of the imagination but
or rather but might be the wrong word
word I think there are very dark almost
identical statements being made by what
we've heard here and Joseph gbl's
Hitler's PR campaign I think it's almost
identical the way they describe them as
subhuman and bear in mind it was Gobles
who paved the way with his PR that paved
the way for the Holocaust by going after
the Germans and pumping them with that
information to say to them this is what
the Jews do the difference this time
however is that where Geral dominated
the entire media in Germany social media
doesn't allow them to dominate the
entire media and that's why I think that
it's ironic even John C even blinkin
blinkin had a statement in the UN where
after Russia bombed the hospital in the
Ukraine and you know blinkin said it's
not normal we can't normalize bombing
hospitals but here we are in festine and
Gaza and they're bombing hospitals and
it's perfectly fine we see John Kirby
John Kirby wept and he cried you know
like over over Ukraine but is making
every semantic gymnastic to justify
saying the Israelis I'm seeing them take
great effort in order to ensure not to
kill civilian G casualties with 15,000
have been killed that's clearly incited
and actually by law she can actually be
prosecuted for that she can be
prosecuted according to what
international law according to she can
be prosecuted for that and in the UK
we've actually seen lawyers come
together in order to threaten
politicians to say if you keep making
these ins we will take you to court and
we've seen some MPS actually tone down
their language because they fear they
can be prosecuted for that as well and
that's
that's good you brought that up people
need to uh hold people like this to
account and that's what I mean in that
here in the US I understand that people
feel under pressure with regards to
what's happening in Gaza but here you do
have laws you can use to push back
against that you do have resources to
deploy to legally push back against that
because it's illegal to incite hatred in
this way it's illegal to incite genocide
in this way and that's why I think that
the difference now as opposed to 911 911
no muslim could justify what happened to
91 11 it's true but the reaction was one
of panic and being insula the difference
this time with GZA is the community is
no longer going insula they're going out
to say look we we want we we condemn
what is wrong and we uphold what is
right this is a genocide apartheid and
ethnic cleansing abundantly clear and
everybody now is deploying the resources
to do it and the reason why they're
making statements such as this is
because they are aware that the social
media has changed the public opinion one
thing I will say is this is is
this the hysterical reaction
the hysteria with which they speak with
correlates directly to their perception
of the threat to Israel's Monopoly over
the narrative the more ridiculous and
outrageous the statement the more they
are terrified over the shift in public
opinion in other words when I hear that
statement it's inciting genocide yes but
for me it's also a reflection of a deep
concern that that rhetoric is not
resonating with the population that that
rhetoric of the past is not resonating
and so there's a need to up the anti in
order to desperately try to restore some
control over a narrative that has been
lost because we're seeing so many people
who were pro-israel yesterday today
become Pro Palestinian I saw a rapper
who said look I don't know much about
Palestine Israel but I know a genocide
when I see one I see the Deputy Prime
Minister of Belgium coming out calling
for sanctions against Israel I see the
Spanish Spain say that we know we're
ready to recognize a Palestinian State I
see macron calling for a ceasefire and
rolling back on his statement where he
said we need an International Coalition
against Hamas he said I didn't mean we
need to wipe out itself I've seen that
when the US tries to establish an
alliance in the Red Sea to counter the
Hui missiles Saudi Arabia refuses to
join UAE refuses to join France withdrew
Spain withdrew Australia refused to join
I'm seeing that in the UN vote when they
did the security Council vote I'm seeing
delays in the vote because us diplomats
wanted time to convince Biden and they
pleaded with Biden and said please don't
use the veto we're becoming a joke in
the United Nations I'm seeing the Daily
Express a right-wing paper in the UK say
people are increasingly no longer taking
the US seriously anymore I'm seeing the
EU say we can't rely on the us anymore
we need to move forward I'm seeing G7
diplomats in Financial Times saying that
we can no longer rely on the global
South to support us in Ukraine anymore
I'm seeing Biden desperately try to
rally support for his plan for the day
after and failing miserably the point is
that statement is outrageous but I read
it from as coming from a position of
weakness because they know they're
losing control of the narrative they
know there are consequences to losing
control of the narrative they know the
world is waking up they know that people
are shifting to Pro Palestine and that
Hy hysterical language is a response to
a hysteria over the fear that for the
first time since
1948 the world is finally seeing what's
really happening in Palestine and that
will have sweeping ramifications for the
future of the discourse with regards to
this conflict very similar to aparti
South Africa when when public opinion
changed not even Margaret Thatcher the
UK prime minister was able to stop the
world from imposing sanctions on South
Africa that led to the fall of the apart
regime and Mandela coming to power uh
what do you think this just came to mind
um I'm enjoying listening to you um they
uh are saying that since the radical the
zionists hijacked the ones who hijacked
Judaism they're trying to take over now
Mash AA and build a third Temple what
are your comments on
this do you know much about this no no
it's not that I'm trying to word it in a
way that that this is the real agenda
now this is this is a topic I explain
what I
mean the former K prime minister Hamed B
Jas put out a tweet one day where he
said there is a Gulf State that is
buying land from the Palestinians and
giving it to the
Israelis now I thought don't like each
other it might be exaggeration a few
friends of mine came back from Palestine
a few months ago and I asked them about
it and they said that they've realized
that family that they they have friends
who have sold land to Arabs and then the
next day they've seen Israeli settlers
turn up on on that land with the title
deed so this isn't settlers occupying
the home this is Settlers saying we
bought the land because it was given to
us by the Arab who bought the land from
the
Palestinians I sat one so my job for
those who don't know is basically I
advise companies how to navigate
political environments for example all
this week I've just been in meetings
with clients every morning because of
the time difference with the US where
they've said look we have our ships
they're approaching the Red Sea should
they cross and and when will this hthi
threat this appear because right now
we're losing millions and that or they
will say for example erdogan passed the
law in 2013 no alcohol after 10 p.m. an
alcohol company will say this will
result in a fall of 35% of our profits
we want to know will erdogan win next
year or not if he's going to win next
year we'll tone down like we'll reel
back our alcohol sales when kasum Suman
was killed in 2019 you know all the
companies they were saying will there be
war between Iran and the us because we
have our operations we don't want to get
caught up it will cost us 50 million to
roll down our operations we really don't
want to do it so we need to be certain
there's going to be War before we make
the decision and then you tell them
there's going to be no war that's that's
my job basically as a political
analyst some of my clients are are
foreign ministries of Western
governments and I sat once in a room
with diplomats in a closed door room as
part of the consultancy process and I
was asked a question as an independent
expert not that I claim to be an expert
but that's what they said it's not me
they said uh do you think that Saudi
Arabia would hand over al- AA to the
Israelis I said no that sounds
ridiculous they said because there's
something that we find quite puzzling
what is it you quite and puzzling when
we talk to our Israeli
counterparts they've told us this is a
done deal like when they speak about Al
AA being handed over to Israel they
don't say there's maybe or we're
negotiating they talk about it like it's
already a done deal so we're quite
confused about you know this idea is
that what the Saudis have said is that
what the U have said and the reason why
I was shocked by it was not because it's
the first time I've heard it but because
if you remember there was an attempted
coup in Jordan last year where King
Abdullah arrested his half brother and
he arrested Saudi man in Jordan which is
who was once Untouchable and then there
was sort of a diplomatic crisis between
and there's also been reports in the
Arab media as well like for the last
couple of years that bin Salman the
Saudi Crown Prince has been pressuring
Jordan to share the custodianship of ala
so for those who don't know the king of
Saudi Arabia
the meah Medina the custodian of the two
holy mosques and King Abdullah of Jordan
is the custodian of ala bin Salman has
been pressuring Jordan to hand over the
custodians sh Al AA to Saudi and UAE as
a joint tripartite thing in the hope
that he'll take it as well when you put
what these European diplomats have said
and this immense pressure on Jordan from
The
Saudis and the dis islamization process
in Saudi Arabia and you know you know
the fwa coming out of Saudi Arabia which
is don't talk about because it's a f and
I have a friend who was going to who's
going to I won't say who so they let him
through
jeda but when he was in Istanbul he told
my wife that tell Sammy
that I received a WhatsApp from the tour
group they told us don't bring cfas to
Saudi Arabia and don't record yourselves
making Dua for and I told my wife I
can't go in a rumance and tell people
this is what's happening when I was in
LA last month for a convention I had
dinner with a group of people and I said
to them guys I'm here hearing that this
is what's happening and one person other
side table went no no it's not a rumor
I'm going to next month here's the
WhatsApp and the WhatsApp says it's with
a heavy heart that we inform you that
we've been told by the Saudi authorities
no CF no record and even I don't know if
you saw today um from the time of this
recording turkey the two Turkish teams
were supposed to play in Saudi Arabia
the teams wanted to unfur a banner of uh
turkey stands in support of Gaza and
they want to put a quote from atat
the Saudis have said if you're going to
unfur a a banner of support for Gazza we
won't allow you to play the game in
Saudi Arabia Jared Kushner two weeks or
three weeks after October 7th was in the
heart of Saudi Arabia at the Davos in
the desert Forum saying at a keynote
speech that the Palestinians wanted to
ruin normalization between Saudi and the
Israelis and they will fail in this and
the Saudis didn't respond to it they
allowed him to say in the heart of Saudi
Arabia and when kushna came back to the
US he told the hillo CNN that as a Jew I
feel safer in Saudi Arabia than I do on
the US campuses meaning that he didn't
receive any backlash over what's what
Israel is doing but he received backlash
of what Israel is doing in the US he
didn't receive in Saudi but he received
in the US Oman closed its airspace to
Israeli planes or the like Saudi still
hasn't closed it airspace to the
Israelis or that the point being is
going back to your question when people
are suggesting that there is a
possibility that the Saudis and UAE will
entertain the prospect of allowing
Israel to have their way with Al AA I
think that based on these Dynamics there
is a very real possibility and this
isn't me saying it when the Saudi
Ambassador Went to went to meet mahm
Abbas in ramala in in in the West
Bank the Reuters reported so I don't
know you remember bin Salman's interview
with Fox News where he said you know
we're getting closer to normalization
every single day and he says we're
willing to accept anything that makes
life easier for the Palestinians doesn't
talk about Palestinian
State Reuters reported that the Saudis
had informed the Americans that as long
as they get a NATO style security
agreement and nuclear technology because
they don't want Iran to have a nuclear
weapon and they don't have one and
support for vision 2030 they are willing
to set aside a demand for a Palestinian
State and then they invited the
Palestinian Authority to riy and offered
a big cash package and then they sent
their Saudi ambassador to ramala the
Saudi Ambassador wanted to go the whole
way and pray in ALA to sort of say that
this is being legitimized religiously
and the Palestinians told him we will
not let him set foot in ALA because we
know the Saudis are about to betray us
so I'm saying what my point is even the
Palestinians are aware that something
ugly is a foot with regards to this idea
of Saudi seeking custodianship over the
Ala Masjid and so to answer your
question I am very uneasy to hear
European diplomats tell me that the
Israelis are telling them that
normalization will mean that ala is
handed over to them and that they will
have their way with I don't know if it
will happen all I'm saying is if these
senior diplomats are saying it somebody
is saying something somewhere M and the
Saudis are not doing enough to rebut it
cuz they could have said to me israels
are saying it and Saudis are
categorically denying it and I will say
one thing final point the other thing I
find deeply disconcerting is that the
diplomats that I speak to say and bear
in mind these are European diplomats
expressing shock at this phenomenon they
said when we talk to our Saudi
counterparts they don't bring up Gazza
they talk to us about neom and vision
2030 we bring up Gaz in the conversation
and we're bit surprised about this and
that's why I think that one of the
reasons Israel has continued its
offensive in my opinion and this is my
responsibility I I'm saying it I'm not
saying it reflects the opinion of
anybody at De show or the like I think
one of the reasons is that Saudi and UAE
privately are telling the Israelis go
get them if it's Hamas go get them Hamas
officials some of them are in prison in
Saudi Arabia if you open alabia or Saudi
Media or UAE media you could be given
for believing that it is Israeli media
the way that they blame the Palestinians
the way that Saudi commentators online
are calling Palestinians ingrates the
way they are saying that it's their
fault that they shouldn't have done it
as if somehow they should have just sat
there and waited for Janine to be
annexed by the Israelis really you sort
of feel like the rhetoric coming out is
one that lends itself to the
suggestion that when Netanyahu said we
thank our friends for understanding
those friends he would talk he was
talking about were Muslim nations not
the Western Nations last question here
um on the premise that and this is what
Islam teaches us uh the Quran revealed
by the creator of heavens and earth that
all human life is precious and you
you've said it multiple times that we
have don't have a problem condemning
evil and being just and fair and I've
interviewed many uh people who are
former zionists former ID of special
force is Miko pillet I don't know if you
know about him his uh great-grandfather
was somebody who helped to uh one of the
original signers of the Declaration of
Independence for uh Israel his
grandfather was a general in the Israeli
Army he's one of the strongest voices
out there today who speaking again who's
speaking on the side of Truth and
Justice and against the apartheid and
oppression and many Jews also who are in
the S side of humanity who their
humanity is on who are against the
killing of innocent human beings the
oppression of human beings there was one
talk he was uh he was on Piers Morgan
his name is Gabor m I don't know if you
he's also visit I don't know if you've
met him he's visited Bosnia also and and
he was talking about uh he was also a
Zionist now look I used to be a Zionist
I'm a as you mentioned I'm a holocaust
Survivor Zionism was very important for
me as a Salvation of the Jewish
people until I found out that the state
was founded based on the extration the
explosion and multiple massacres of the
local population and that's not
historically
controversial and then he just could not
his Humanity was on and he could not
silence it seeing the oppression so he
these are people who are going against
the odds and then he also now he was
talking he he had some uh resistance
obviously from his father and his family
members but after some time they also
came along because their Humanity people
go through a a state of cognitive
dissonance so what are you seeing and
and what what would you say say to the
people who are witnessing this and so
they don't have to go to a long state of
cognizant dissonance and you know and
tomorrow be on the wrong side of History
to be on the right side of history and
to look at voices like this Norman
finlin and others who put their neck on
the line what do they have to win they
have a lot to lose but they're on the
side of Truth so for the audience that's
listening a lot of this we went through
so many different points you addressed
it very clear what do you have uh to say
for the person who doesn't know but now
they're learning and they
are they've been programmed with a lot
of the uh the programming that's out
there what would you say to them I think
one of the things that is worth noting
is we call it Humanity yeah in Islam
there's a concept of the F we say the
prophet muham was sent as a Mercy to
Mankind he wasn't sent to a chosen
people he was sent to Mankind and the
reason being is that we believe as
Muslims that every human being has a
conscience and that conscience we call
the F and the fitra resonates
with Justice and hates naturally hates
Injustice every human being is capable
of this and that's why I argue that the
reason we have so many allies now with
regards to what's happening in festine
and we see gab M and nor is their is
screaming out that there is an injustice
that is taking place that they cannot
find and the role of Justice in Islam is
so important that
said Justice is the foundation of all
dominion and oppression Heralds the end
of a dynasty and what
said was even was even more profound
actually said that Allah will preserve a
non-muslim state that is just but
destroy a Muslim state that is unjust
for Allah tolerates kufur disbelief with
Justice but does not tolerate Islam with
Injustice the point being is that this
is why for the Muslim themselves Justice
is at the Pinnacle regardless of who it
is Muslim or non-muslim if a Muslim
doesn't stand for justice they are
abandoning one of the basic tenents of
Islam that according to will lead to the
destruction of the Muslim State no
matter how many mosques it has or how
many people are praying in those Mass
the reason why I say this is to show you
the link between Justice and F the link
between Justice and how it resonates
with people who are now coming out for
the sake of the Palestine or the like
and that's why I think the reality is
that when and I'm giving these
Traditions to show how it resonates with
the F Omar ABD received a message from
one of his Governors and he said I have
unruly tribes the same way that people
Israel is trying to say that these
Palestinians you know they're barbarians
or they can only know Force I'm giving
advice to the Israelis from
Islam when the governor sent he said
please send me a relief Force an army so
that I can control these barbaric
tribes replies and he said so he says
you know um the word that he uses I want
to fortify it with an army and repli
replies fortify with Justice you don't
need an army give rights to the
Palestinians give their Justice give
them the right of return let them have
their lands back let them have their
homes back they were unjustly kicked and
you will find that the Palestinian
Vendetta was never against the Jew the
Palestinian Vendetta was never against
the the Jewish population the Muslims
never had a vendetta against the Jew the
Muslims only had a vendetta against
Injustice whether it was the Jews or
whoever who who stood with Injustice
Muslims don't have any problem with
regards to the Jews or the Christians or
the like it's only with Injustice
restore the justice and everybody lives
fine in peace everybody lives fine in
coexistence because it's Injustice that
leads to the cycle of violence over and
over again the same way that Gab mate
told P Morgan it's the Injustice that
leads to the cycle of violence over and
over again he used the example of the
Hungarian Revolution he used the example
of something it's the Injustice that
leads to this NeverEnding violence that
we're seeing everybody's focusing on the
symptom and not the disease when you
restore the Justice there's no need need
to resort to these violence I'm not
saying that violence is Justified I'm
saying that violence doesn't emerge from
Justice it emerges from Injustice and
that's the point I want to say in that
now we have all these allies that are
emerging who are resonating with their f
is resonating with the justice and
that's the point why I want to emphasize
even to Muslims who are listening when
Allah gives the example of Da that we
mentioned earlier and he gives the next
Ayah where he says for the one who you
had enmity with today and enmity here
could be that they supported Injustice
before today they support Justice you
gave the example gab mate says I love
the idea of Israel before until I saw
its reality many people are now seeing
that reality and that's something to
celebrate something that we can welcome
because what Humanity agrees upon is
Justice what Humanity agrees upon is
that Justice is the essence of
coexistence and the way that we operate
in society the reason we Muslims believe
that Islam is the true religion is
because Islam shows you how to achieve
that Justice in its interaction with
other religions in the way that we
explained earlier the coexistence in a
way that Europe never managed to achieve
under the white supremacist anti-semitic
it was Islam that created the Jerusalem
of Europe Saro and created Cordoba and
Granada which became the Andalusia the
it was Islam created something that
Christendom never created that Judaism
never created that's why we're asserting
that we have we know what Justice looks
like but I think it's a wonderful
phenomenon that people are now seeing
the justice for what it is that we're
seeing more allies emerge gabo mate no
has always been in that position and the
like but we're seeing Ordinary People
also start to read and start to ask
because what prevented the Palestinian
narrative from being delivered was a
desperate Israeli attempt to prevent it
and that's why I think that there was a
really interesting Tik Tok video where
they showed an African-American doing a
video where she she does it like a
sketch where she says you know she's
pretending to talk to someone and she
says you know oh my God they attacked us
on October 7th and you know these
barbarians and they killed civilians oh
my God why did they do that I I I don't
know they're just barbari is just humans
oh my God I'm scared like what kind of
world is this where people can just get
up and attack you I need to read about
this no no no don't read about it don't
read about it don't no no I need to
don't read about it and then she looks
and says oh you've been hoodwinking me
all this time about what's actually
happening and and that's why I think
that what they're resonating with first
and foremost is an innate sense of
justice that exists in every human being
a f and hopefully and as we've seen in
this thing that F ultimately leads them
to ask questions and we've seen a wave
of people entering Islam as a result
because they realized that there was a
wall that Israel had erected and when
that wall was smashed as a result of
social media when finally people ask
questions when finally they read about
the issue when finally they wanted to
understand what was happening they found
that there was only one truth and that
was M beautiful beautiful way to end I I
like that uh where people are looking
who've already been searching and
thinking what's the purpose of life
they're saying people's life destroyed
they're still holding on to that purpose
of
the the that there's nothing worthy of
worship of the creator of heavens and
earth Muhammad is his messenger thank
you very much samam for being with us
and helping uh us and the people
understand the history here and what's
brought us here today and some of the
solutions thank you for having
me now You' probably heard the following
misconceptions before Islam preaches
violence Muslims are terrorists the
Quran teaches hate Surah 9 is the most
violent chapter of the Quran we know
these are lies s like brothers and
sisters it's your brother Eddie from
from the dean show and I want to invite
you to take part in this opportunity of
a lifetime we're on a mission to shatter
these myths and shine a light on the
beauty of Islam this is why we need to
support the dean Center so we're here on
the property at the dean Center we might
not have billions of dollars like
Hollywood or the global news channels
but we got something more important our
unwavering faith and people like you who
stand behind us this is a Uma project we
need a lot of support that's where you
guys come in the dean Center will be a
bridge of understanding for everyone
seeking knowledge in understanding Islam
and Muslims Let's Be the Change Let's Be
The Voice stand with us and let's make a
difference one heart at a time click the
link below donate right now may God
Almighty Allah reward all of
you I cannot leave without giving you a
gift if you're not yet Muslim and you
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go ahead and visit theen
show.com we'll take care of the postage
and everything and get it delivered to
you and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 1 1800
66247 52 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam